جميع راكبي الأمواج لكنهم يريدون القدوم إلى
أمريكا الجنوبية بسبب الفرامل ذات النقطة الصحيحة ،
لدينا فرامل نقطية مثالية
لدينا الكثير من الفرص من الشمال
إلى الصحراء إلى الجنوب
[موسيقى]
اعتاد تاليهوتاي القدوم عندما كنت صغيرًا
إنه المكان المناسب لك إذا كنت ترغب في ركوب الأمواج ،
فهو يشبه نوعًا ما قرية ركوب الأمواج
في المغرب ، حيث
يعيش الناس من تعليم ركوب
الأمواج في مدارس ركوب الأمواج والأشياء التي تغيرت
كثيرًا ، أعني أنها لم تكن
كذلك في السابق ، ثم إنها تنمو بسرعة وأنا  آمل أن
تستمر لأن لدينا الكثير من
الإمكانات هنا ، أنا من مدينة
قريبة جدًا من هنا ، لقد حصلت
عليك وكان علينا فقط القيادة لمدة 15 دقيقة
وسنخرج مثل العاهرات اللطيفات حتى لو
لم أفعل  ركوب الأمواج حتى لو كانت الأمواج سيئة. أنا
لا أهتم بالقيادة فقط ، لذلك تستيقظ
في الصباح ، تذهب إلى نقطة الربط ، وتتحقق من
ذلك جيدًا ، بدأ شغفي
بركوب الأمواج عندما كنت في التاسعة
أو العاشرة من عمري تقريبًا وقفت على اللوح
وأنا أحب الشعور الذي
تعرفه  وأنا لا
أعرف الوقوف فقط ، وأرغب في الذهاب
إلى الشاطئ طوال اليوم ، كنت أرتدي
بذلة الغوص في الصباح ،
وأتذكر وأعتني بها في الليل ، وأبقى على
الطريق طوال اليوم.  عندما أعود
إلى تلك الأماكن
بنفس الشعور ، فإن الشعور نفسه هو
قريتي فقط ، وحتى لو مرت 15
عامًا الآن عندما أعود ، فهو
دائمًا نفس الشعور
بأنه منزلي
أوه